u.s secretary of state mike pompeo is
visiting denmark
to try to persuade it to stop work on
the nord stream 2
gas pipeline passing through its waters
denmark has just given the go-ahead for
the work
but pompeo hopes to get the danes to
change their minds
the us believes the pipeline will make
germany too dependent
on russian gas
now last week pompeo warned companies
involved in the project
they will be subject to u.s penalties if
they didn't halt their work
work on the baltic sea gas pipeline
nordstrom 2
is still moving forward albeit slowly
the u.s has threatened sanctions for
companies participating in the project
so right now there's just one russian
ship laying the pipes for the remaining
160 kilometers
the pipeline runs parallel to the nord
stream one pipeline from russia to
germany
one thousand two hundred kilometers
across the baltic
once complete it will allow russia to
supply double the current volume of gas
the united states says germany is making
itself dependent on russia earlier this
month
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo
warned against continuing to build the
pipeline
this action puts investments or other
activities that are related to these
russian energy export pipelines
at risk of u.s sanctions it's a clear
warning to companies
aiding and abetting russia's malign
influence projects
will not be tolerated get out now or
risk the consequences germany has
rejected the criticism and says
sanctions would be contrary to
international law
now denmark has given permission for
additional vessels to work
on the last phase of the pipeline within
its territorial waters
that means work on the project may soon
pick up speed
angering pompeo and the white house
so how exactly is the german government
reacting to this latest
u.s diplomatic offensive against
nordstrom 2.
dw's chief political editor michela
kufner spoke to german defense
minister anagret crump karen bauer
north stream is a project that is also
being debated among eu but also
nato member states
there is concern that germany could
become too dependent on russian gas
a concern we were able to defuse but
it's also about the concerns and the
legitimate interests of ukraine and
poland
which have to be negotiated into the
contracts
and when it comes to the u.s threat of
sanctions we in the german government
have the clear position that these are
not in accordance with international law
and michaela who conducted that
interview joins us now from our politics
studio michaela
underground karan bauer isn't just
germany's defense minister she's also
the chair
of chancellor angela merkel's cdu party
and of course a close ally
of the chancellor what else did she have
to say about the north stream pipeline
controversy
well you can sense that there is a high
level of concern over what the united
states may do
next at the same time i also know from
previous conversations that she never
was a big fan of this particular project
in fact there were german mps
european mps who signed up against it
saying that it weakened
europe's integrity and sovereignty
particularly towards russia
and with the u.s of course applying
pressure and having its very own
interests of selling um
liquefied gas to the european union so
for now the german
government is trying to build a bridge
by
building also a new port for gas that
could be imported from the united states
but clearly there is a deadlock here and
referring to international law that's
the big questions how far
that argument will get the german
government which after all
continues to say that the u.s are their
closest ally
and speaking of the u.s the trump
administration has taken
a very hard line on this pipeline but
with uh presidential elections due in
four months time
do you think berlin is thinking of just
sitting out this confrontation for now
well of course berlin has also heard all
the politicians hear that joe biden the
democrat candidate
um has vowed to review all decisions
taken by the trump government
that may include north stream too at the
same time there's also very strong
voices
in congress that are opposed to it so it
probably won't be that easy
um at the same time the german
government has learned to live
with a certain level of aggravation with
the united states
for now also focusing on stability
within nato and keeping
the current government on its side when
it comes to
key defense issues but north stream 2
simply won't go away
at the same time the german government
couldn't afford to give ground
because that would be seen as basically
having lost
a standoff not just with washington but
also with brussels
dw's chief political editor michelle
kufner thank you so much
you